[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public vous le
savez la promesse et dans le titre
donner du sens à l'actualité se mettre
au service du public vous proposez tous
les soirs des clés de compréhension des
mutations de notre société et voici le
sommaire de ce 15 décembre 67 % des
Français pensent que la réforme des
retraites est une mauvaise réforme c'est
le résultat du dernier baromètre odoxal
mascara de l'année on va analyser les
résultats en détail évidemment j'ai
aussi proposé à mes invités de jeter un
coup d'oeil dans le rétroviseur de 2022
ils ont choisi leur événement politique
marquant on va les découvrir ensemble
tout à l'heure et puis cette question
dans 10 jours sous le sapin de Noël
mettez-vous des cadeaux de seconde main
pouvoir d'achat en berne et engagement
environnemental sont les deux leviers
d'un marché de l'occasion qui décolle
notamment pour les jouets
tout simplement on sait bien que les
joys ils ont une vie très longue et que
les enfants ils jouent très peu avec
donc moi j'achète beaucoup de jouets de
seconde main qui sont de bonne qualité
et ça se passe très bien 2022 l'année du
premier Noël éco-responsable on en débat
dans 45 minutes mais d'abord on se
projette au début de l'année 2023 quand
le gouvernement présentera son texte sur
les retraites le défi sera de taille
convaincre une opinion et des Français
toujours vend debout mathiasaraez
c'est une réforme largement impopulaire
avec plus de deux Français sur trois
opposés à un report de l'âge de départ à
la retraite le gouvernement pourrait
faire face à un rejet massif nous allons
dans les semaines qui viennent continuer
de faire de la pédagogie d'expliquer
l'importance de cette réforme
l'importance de pérenniser un des
fondements de notre modèle social sous
cette solidarité intergénérationnelle
qui est spécifique à notre pays et qui
est depuis des années maintenant au cœur
de même de notre cohésion
professionnelle et notre cohésion
sociale et elle est menacée cette
cohésion s'il n'arrivons pas à
pérenniser notre système par répartition
de retraite du côté des sympathisants
des républicains l'adhésion un recul de
la retraite à 65 ans est nettement plus
forte de sur 3 ils sont favorables
quitte à contredire la position d'une
partie de leur parlementaire je pense
qu'on peut aboutir parfaitement au même
résultat de façon beaucoup plus
équilibrée en jouant à la fois sur le
report de l'âge légal et aussi sur la
durée de cotisation c'est moins brutal
c'est progressif et on obtient la même
chose en termes de soutenabilité
budgétaire un projet attendu pour le 10
janvier qui ne semble pas égratigner la
popularité de l'exécutif avec 36%
d'opinions favorables la première
ministre Elisabeth borne talonne de
justesse le chef de l'État et ses 41%
allez on va analyser en détail les
résultats de ce baromètre avec Gall
Slimane évidemment président
co-fondateur de doxa bonsoir bonsoir
Thomas bienvenue à vous Catherine tricot
bonsoir bienvenue directrice de la revue
regarde accueille également Bruno
cotreize bonsoir Bruno politologue
chercheur
avec nous duplex Yves Sancy bonsoir vous
êtes Seigneur partner chez mascareg donc
l'un de nos partenaires pour ce
baromètre on l'a bien compris et Elise
appelle ski bonsoir Émilie vous êtes
éditorialiste et spécialiste en
communication politique faut-il le
rappeler alors je rappelle le chiffre
principal de ce de ce baromètre on l'a
vu dans dans le sujet de Mathias cette
réponse non à la question pensez-vous
que la réforme des retraites est une
bonne réforme Gael Simon c'est une
confirmation mais c'est intéressant si
on analyse tiens par exemple en fonction
des sympathies politiques c'est assez
éclairant c'est ce qui a été dit
d'ailleurs très justement dans le sujet
donc c'est une mauvaise réforme pour les
deux tiers des Français et
c'est un petit peu le jour sans fin le
jour de la marmotte je sais plus comment
s'appelle ce film c'est la journée de la
marmotte à chaque fois qu'on repose la
question les gens sont au moins ils ont
le mérite de la constance ça aussi
l'entre 68 67 72 % de rejet à chaque
fois qu'il est question d'une réforme
des retraites qui implique de un report
de l'âge légal de départ et donc bon
c'est pas une surprise c'est une
confirmation mais vous avez raison
Thomas quand on regarde plus en détail
c'est intéressant d'un point de vue de
tactique politique parce que il y a deux
catégories de profils de population qui
se montrent favorable à cette réforme
des retraites on l'a vu dans dans le
dans le slide qui était montré les
sympathisants LR et les sympathisants LR
les deux tiers d'entre eux disent si si
il faut le faire c'est une bonne réforme
et puis bien sûr les sympathisants
Renaissance Aix la République en marche
parce que c'est une réforme portée par
le gouvernement et qu'il soutiennent
toujours très majoritairement les
réformes portées par le gouvernement
mais à part ça toutes les catégories de
population ils sont massivement hostiles
c'est parfois une très grande hostilité
notamment auprès des catégories
populaires qui vivent cela une très
grande injustice il y a des différences
en fonction des âges alors il y a des
différences en fonction des âges c'est
toujours cocasse pour moi depuis 20 ans
quand on fait des des questions sur les
réformes des retraites les plus
favorables à une réforme des retraites
qui sont pas touchés impliquant le
départ à la retraite sont ceux qui ne
sont plus touchés que les jeunes même
les étudiants voient ça d'un mauvais œil
sont pas directement tout de suite
concernés ils se disent ça va leur
arriver plus tard alors que les plus de
65 ans les personnes à la retraite elles
sont nettement plus favorables à cette
réforme qui concerne les autres mais à
part cette petite boutade mais qui est
bien réelle sinon vous avez ce rejet qui
est très important qui est constant et
on entendait dans votre sujet
Bruno Retailleau
dire qu'il préférait jouer sur d'autres
critères on pouvait s'étonner pour
quelqu'un de droite fillioniste en plus
c'est étonnant il y a un truc qu'il faut
remarquer quand même qui est constant
aussi c'est que les français si vraiment
il n'y a pas le choix ils nous disent
quand même qu'il trouverait plus juste
quitte à partir plus tard de jouer sur
la durée de cotisation plutôt que sur le
report de l'âge légal petit bémol quand
même sur le sujet sur un point il est
dit ça n'atteint pas l'exécutif en fait
moi je crois que ça atteint durement
Elisabeth borne qui baisse de façon
assez nette on va en parler dans un
instant alors qu'Emmanuel Macron lui est
préservé puisque il est aux États-Unis
il est au Qatar il préside il prend de
la hauteur
qui concerne sa première ministre alors
justement Catherine tricot Emmanuel
Macron c'est lui qui a annoncé le report
de de la présentation par le
gouvernement ça devait être là c'est en
cette fin de semaine ce sera début
janvier vers le 10 janvier
il a eu raison mais il prend le bourreau
il nous semble
lui qui porte cette réforme c'est lui
qui nous mois de septembre nous a dit on
va avoir des coupures d'électricité
maintenant qui dit à tout le monde non
non mais faut pas s'inquiéter qui va au
Qatar en effet si il prend il prend la
lumière quoi Emmanuel Macron il prend
des bonnes les bonnes nouvelles et puis
il laissait Elisabeth borne tant bien
que mal à 49,3 et c'est pas génial mais
s'il avait gardé le calendrier initial
c'était aujourd'hui c'était anti climax
là on est on est on est Coupe du Monde
et Noël quoi on peut on peut dire ça
comme ça c'est quand même pas tout à
fait une surprise qu'on était le 15
décembre à 9h voilà c'est ça ce que
j'allais vous dire je voulais juste
faire une petite remarque à propos du
sondage tout à l'heure c'est quand vous
disiez tout à l'heure que les deux
familles politiques qui soutenaient
cette réforme c'était les républicains
mais les républicains réduit à pas grand
chose quand même c'est à dire que si on
arrive à 67% des Français qui refusent
cette réforme ça veut dire qu'en fait
quand vous avez pris toute en marche bah
il vous reste les républicains à 4,5%
c'est à dire ce qu'ils ont fait à
l'élection présidentielle or tout le
problème des républicains et c'est je
pense que c'est vraiment un moment
extrêmement périlleux pour eux que cette
affaire des réformes des retraites parce
qu'il va falloir qu'ils prennent
position contre finalement la position
de
de l'électorat plus largement que
simplement leur stricte petite chapelle
de 5 6% qui a voté qui a voté Valérie
Pécresse évidemment sur le défi que ça
représente pour pour le parti LR Bruno
cotresses pourquoi il s'obstine et
Madame Macron
ça doit être un marqueur de ce
il a pas le choix d'une part parce que
il avait engagé une réforme des
retraites dans la fin de son premier
mandat qui était stoppé par le covid
aussi par la crise des gilets jaunes qui
étaient en toile de fond bien évidemment
c'est un point qui l'a représenté lors
de sa campagne présidentielle avec
beaucoup d'engagements il leur réitéré à
plusieurs reprises en disant il y aura
une réforme des retraites ça serait
l'une des principales réforme que je
ferai en priorité donc il y a deux ce
point de vue là il met en jeu son image
de réformateur
on fait cette analyse depuis plusieurs
mois et en fait c'est en fait la
première
discussion négociations
et puis surtout il y avait un syndicat
là société qui était favorable parce que
c'est ce qui produit depuis longtemps
mais la première réforme correspondait à
ses fondamentalement à la perception
qu'à Emmanuel Macron à son analyse au
fond des blocages de la société
française et à quelque chose qui était
qui avait le mérite d'une forme de très
grande cohérence avec son projet initial
l'idée de dire au fond il faut qu'un
seul tuyau appelons-nous qu'Emmanuel
Macron dans sa première campagne
présidentielle proposée par exemple que
les travailleurs indépendants puissent
émerger au chômage dorénavant donc voilà
c'était toujours cette idée on va dire
de de casser ce qu'il percevait être des
rampes de situations de la société
française et de reformater notre modèle
social c'était de ce projet extrêmement
cohérent avec son projet présidentiel de
2016-2017 là il se rabat vers une
réforme des retraites classiques tel
qu'on en a déjà connu plusieurs en
France c'est-à-dire un simple
paramétrage sur soi la durée de
cotisation soit la durée d'âge légale de
départ en retraite c'est-à-dire quelque
chose qui a perdu fondamentalement tout
originalité qui est perçue par les
Français comme une simple mesure
technique qui demande des sacrifices et
qui ne prend plus sens et c'est ça la
difficulté aujourd'hui ça ne prend pas
sens à l'intérieur d'un projet global de
société qui parlerait des grandes
injustices prolonger la vie au travail
très bien mais pour faire quoi pour
continuer à progresser dans l'échelle
des salaires par exemple ou pas pour
végéter dans un poste où tout le monde
attend que vous partez en retraite donc
voilà les questions fondamentales et de
ce point de vue là la réforme telle
qu'elle est présentée ne trouve pas de
sens si on évoquait le le climat ambiant
dans les médias sociaux dans les réseaux
sociaux on parle pas beaucoup de
retraite il y a plutôt une petite bulle
d'optimisme là qui grandit en ce moment
c'est ça oui alors il y a une certaine
ambivalence parce que il y a une bulle
d'optimisme qui apparaît très clairement
avec un numéro un des conversations
positives évidemment la Coupe du Monde
et les victoires de la France qui a
extrêmement poly positive et le climat
et deuxièmement de Noël et alors on a un
petit peu l'impression qu'on a une sorte
de de le rêve de Noël en tout cas avec
quand même des signaux ce qu'on appelle
des signaux faibles qui reviennent sur
les problématiques d'inflation
d'augmentation du du coût évidemment de
la vie du coup des cours à la
consommation puisque la consommation des
prix à la consommation alimentaire sont
bien au-delà de l'inflation moyenne et
ça on le voit avec l'apparition
un succès même historique du hashtag
concours c'est à dire qu'il y a un
phénomène assez incroyable sur les
réseaux sociaux autour des concours qui
sont lancés par les les opérateurs de
grande consommation donc c'est un on va
appeler ça une trêve de Noël avant avant
la tempête inflationniste peut-être je
vous propose d'entendre deux réactions
parce que ils avaient de borne continue
ses consultations sur cette réforme des
retraites à Matignon donc deux réactions
à la sortie le député horizon Frédéric
Valtou et puis d'abord Patrick canner
qui préside le groupe socialiste au
Sénat
on attendait rien mais on est quand même
déçu
très simplement et on considère
aujourd'hui que la seule préoccupation
et ça a été rappelé par madame la
ministre c'est le rendement le mot de
rendement financier de la réforme a été
utilisée donc c'est pas l'intérêt des
Français qui est en jeu c'est combien de
milliards on va économiser les choses
sont dans le bon sens on se donne un peu
de temps pour effectivement arriver à
des convergences comme l'a dit à
l'instant Jean-Paul Mattei il y a
effectivement des vrais sujets qui
émergent autour de la pénibilité autour
de la reconnaissance aussi des carrières
longues et l'ajustement donc un système
qui est capable de faire beaucoup plus
de dentelle et d'accompagnement
peut-être que il n'était jusqu'à présent
émilie a passé quand même un sacré défi
de communicant quoi convaincre l'opinion
que cette réforme est indispensable mais
je crois que Patrick
de cette réforme est-ce que c'est pour
faire des économies et pour investir
ailleurs est-ce que c'est pour augmenter
l'âge pour du rendement comme il disait
à quoi ça va servir et là on a plus de
lisibilité du tout sur les objectifs et
du coup on y va pas et on y voit ce
qu'on veut y voir c'est à dire bah ça
repousse l'âge donc moi j'ai pas envie
de travailler plus si en plus j'ai
commencé tôt ou va m'amener à travailler
beaucoup beaucoup plus longtemps et j'ai
pas du tout envie de le faire il y a un
problème de ce côté-là il avait commencé
à essayer d'expliquer en disant ça va
nous permettre de dégager de l'argent
pour investir ailleurs mais il a
abandonné cet argumentaire là et du coup
chacun le fait à sa méthode à sa façon
et cet argumentaire Catherine tricot il
pourrait porter auprès justement des
sympathisants LR dont vous parliez tout
à l'heure ah ben oui tout à fait c'est
l'argument qui peut à la dette
en même temps les sympathisants LR ils
sont ils vivent pas en dehors de la
réalité c'est à dire que même ils
peuvent trouver ils peuvent avoir peur
du chômage pour eux c'est à dire que si
on a plus de travail à 58 ou 59 ans la
fin de carrière ça annonce très très
très très compliqué c'est à dire c'est
du RSA à la fin de ça mais de sa vie
professionnelle avant de rentrer en
retraite donc c'est quand même pas les
sympathisants LR ils vivent pas tout à
fait perché quoi donc ce que je pense
c'est que le fait que les gens ne
veulent pas c'est soit des problèmes de
sens soit des problèmes d'inquiétude
c'est est-ce que je vais pouvoir est-ce
que physiquement je vais pouvoir le
faire est-ce que mentalement je vais
pouvoir le faire par exemple les
professeurs est-ce qu'ils peuvent aller
est-ce que les infirmières peuvent aller
au travail jusqu'à 65 ans et puis
dernière chose c'est est-ce que je vais
avoir du travail c'est est-ce que
j'aurai moi est-ce que je vais être en
emploi au moment du départ à la retraite
on sait qu'aujourd'hui les gens ne sont
pas en emploi donc moi ce que je crois
c'est que le il y a un discours qui
semble un petit peu éthéré un petit peu
au-dessus de la réalité et du ressenti
par tout le monde en soie un électeur LR
Nupe ou rassemblement national et vous
disiez Gaëlle que si le président de la
République dans sa cote de popularité ne
souffre pas il progresse de trois points
je crois ils avaient devant en revanche
elle elle empathie bah il a dit
elisabethi puisque on est dans une
période où il y a aussi les bonnes
nouvelles qui évoquées à l'instant ils
sont si pour mascara et qui existent sur
le football sur les fêtes de Noël qui
approche donc les choses
et puisque le football la Coupe du Monde
c'est important quand même donc une
victoire en Coupe du Monde près de 21
millions de téléspectateurs
en Coupe du Monde Jacques Chirac en 95
ça lui avait fait du bien donc on est
plutôt dans une période où elle pourrait
engranger des poils ne le fait pas parce
qu'elle se coltine vous l'évoquez tous
les tous les sujets difficiles je
rejoins ce que vous dites quand même sur
cette réforme de retraite si vraiment il
n'a pas le choix il doit le faire
puisqu'il s'est engagé c'est la seule
chose qu'on retenait les gens de la
campagne présidentielle d'Emmanuel
Macron mais c'est à dire que c'est sans
doute pour ça qu'il l'a fait parce qu'on
se disait pourquoi il a changé de pied
sur la réforme pour annoncer quelque
chose de nouveau parce qu'il aurait il
aurait dit on va on va faire la réforme
qu'on avait qu'on a dû abandonner à
cause de à cause du covid c'était
compliqué aussi parce que la difficulté
c'est que l'ancienne réforme on a un
gros baromètre qu'on réalise
régulièrement pour GG V sur le rapport à
la retraite des Français et c'est un
sujet d'angoisse majeur pour eux et dans
ce qu'on observe sur ce sujet d'angoisse
majeur il y avait des éléments des
angles sur lesquels il pourrait
s'appuyer le front peut-être remarquer
sur notamment les femmes parce que quand
on observe ce qui se passe à la retraite
aujourd'hui entre les femmes et les
hommes il y a des inégalités qui sont
absolument dingues sur la pension qu'on
va toucher et sur l'âge auquel on
pourrait partir et dans la première
réforme ils avaient réfléchi à cela ils
avaient travaillé là-dessus ça n'a
jamais imprimé dans l'opinion puisque
dans les enquêtes les femmes étaient
encore plus hostiles à la réforme que
les hommes mais ils disposait de billes
ou d'éléments sur lesquels ils auraient
peut-être pu jouer ils n'ont pas fait et
au lieu de ça on a ce sentiment enfin
les Français on se sent on va me faire
bosser plus longtemps et en plus en
jouant sur l'âge qui est la mesure la
plus la plus injuste puisque quelqu'un
qui a commencé à travailler un peu jeune
à 20 ans par exemple ou à 19 ans et ben
il va devoir travailler quand même
jusqu'à 65 ans et donc cotiser 45 ans
donc il y a tous ces aspects-là qui qui
existent et qui rendent très compliqué
le fait de manier ce sujet j'ajoute que
si en plus on repasse par du 49-3 c'est
une des questions qu'on a posé dans le
sondage là les gens trouvent ça
carrément inacceptable
peut-être la plus simple à comprendre
aussi s'il y a moi je vous redonne la
parole pour pour boucler ce premier
thème autour des retraites parce
qu'après on va on va découvrir vos
événements marquants de la l'année 2022
donc faut garder du temps pour ça je
repose la même question que ça va être
Macron pourquoi il a pourquoi il a
changé de pied si vous avez pensé
totalement répondu je pense que
fondamentalement il change de pied parce
que il n'a pas le il n'a pas la
possibilité véritablement politique
d'aller au-delà et de faire le vrai
projet qui lui tient qui lui tient à
cœur qui pas celui-ci et on voit bien la
difficulté de l'exécutif si on prenait
une balance on voit que l'exécutif
essaye de mettre d'un côté de la balance
des éléments mais qui sont complètement
usés dans du point de genre perception
de le pion les carrières longues la
pénibilité c'est un vocabulaire qu'on
utilise sans arrêt sans arrêt la
question de l'employabilité des seniors
qui est aussi un argument fréquemment
évoqué le niveau minimum d'une pension
1100 euros
mais de l'autre côté de la balance si
effectivement ce que les gens vivent eux
concrètement et qui entendent l'exécutif
dire je vais faire un truc génial pour
vous c'est que personne ne peut avoir
son nombre d'annuités et toucher moins
de 1100 euros on a un pays très riche
voilà le message qu'on envoie donc c'est
pas lisible la question de la pénibilité
des carrières longues c'est un
vocabulaire qui paraît un peu éthéré un
peu technocratique les gens voudraient
savoir exactement qu'est-ce que ça
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire beaucoup de
gens qui souffrent au travail
psychologiquement physiquement donc
voilà il y a une grande difficulté pour
l'exécutif de ce point de vue là à
équilibrer les deux plateaux de la le
plateau de la balance et à dire je mets
autant qu'il va vous en coûter va vous
en coûter de travailler plus longtemps
mais alors par contre voilà ce que vous
allez gagner concrètement et l'exécutive
a beaucoup de mal et Emmanuel Macron le
fait parce que fondamentalement s'il ne
fait pas ça son image de réformateur qui
est encore là on va dire le cœur de son
de sa popularité dans son cœur
d'électorat chez les républicains aussi
ça compte cette image de Macron de
réformateur s'il fait pas ça l'image de
Macron de réformateur c'est c'est fini
son caricaturé c'est quand même une
demande aussi européenne il faut que le
budget autorisé pour les retraites soit
14% du PIB on va vers une augmentation
des seniors donc en fait l'équation elle
est simple ça veut dire qu'on va donner
moins d'argent pour les retraites
c'est-à-dire ils peuvent nous le
raconter comme ci comme ci comme ça la
vérité c'est que ce qu'on veut c'est
réduire l'argent qui va être il y aura
la même masse d'argent pour plus de
monde et donc on va diviser et c'est
quand même un grand débat sur les
retraites il faut juste se souvenir que
dans les années 60 il y avait quatre
actifs oui mais dans un retraité donc
aujourd'hui on est à 1,7 et ça continue
de baisser donc la question des 14% peut
se discuter c'est ça que je veux dire
c'est que combien on attribue d'argent
dans notre richesse nationale à la
question des retraites ça peut être une
discussion nationale or ça n'est pas une
discussion et moi je pense que ça
devrait l'être parce que s'il y a plus
de vieux il faut plus d'argent pour les
vieux voilà
allez comme promis on va faire ensemble
le bilan de cette année politique bilan
non exhaustif totalement subjectif
puisque vous avez choisi chacune et
chacun un seul événement marquant enfin
vous avez une petite liste avec deux
trois et puis nous on a dit bon bah ce
sera ça et ça voilà on vous ouvre les
portes de la cuisine de deux sens public
mais alors avant de vous entendre je
propose à table traduis de me rejoindre
de nous rejoindre sur ce plateau bonsoir
madame tour d'horizon des textes adoptés
au Sénat depuis la réélection d'Emmanuel
Macron et non exhaustif alors vous avez
l'impression que tous sont adoptés par
le 49-3 depuis le début de ce nouveau
quinquennat que nenni alors certes oui
la routine d'Elizabeth borne c'est
aujourd'hui trois jours par semaine
voire trois nuits par semaine à
l'Assemblée pour dégainer l'article 49-3
mais au Sénat et bien le gouvernement
les sénateurs joue une autre partition
sur les textes budgétaires comme le
projet de loi de finance 2023 ou encore
le budget de la Sécurité sociale pour
l'année prochaine les sénateurs ont
d'abord affiché lors des Accords ils ont
mis les textes à leur sauce en première
lecture on va prendre deux exemples
premier exemple ils ont ajouté au budget
de la Sécu la retraite à 64 ans et la
hausse de la durée de cotisation contre
la vie du gouvernement on va voir si ça
va évoluer l'année prochaine et puis sur
le budget un autre exemple ils ont par
exemple supprimer un article qui
suscitait la grogne des élus locaux un
article qui instaurait ce que le
gouvernement appelé des contrats de
confiance avec les collectivités
s'agissait pas de fournir au maire de
l'électroménager d'une célèbre en scène
mais de leur demander de limiter la
hausse de leurs dépenses et notez
d'ailleurs que finalement le
gouvernement a renoncé à cette
disposition comme quoi les débats dans
cette chambre n'ont pas été tout à fait
vain d'ailleurs écoutez ce matin Gabriel
Attal qui a fait l'inventaire des
apports du Sénat
cette version 2023 largement inspirée
par les travaux du Sénat je pense à
l'amendement de Madame Gatel sur les
communes nouvelles je pense à
l'amendement du sénateur Delcros sur la
dotation biodiversité beaucoup d'autres
mesures pourraient ici être mentionnées
et être cité
voilà il les brosse dans le sens du poil
mais ça ne trompe personne finalement il
y a que 10% des amendements du Sénat qui
ont été retenus le gouvernement a
conservé ce qu'il voulait de cet acte en
passant par le 49-3 alors il y a aussi
ces textes sur lesquels le gouvernement
a pu s'appuyer sur les sénateurs surtout
les sénateurs de droite et oui notamment
deux projets de loi de finance
rectificative qui consistaient pour
l'essentiel en des mesures en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat et puis surtout la
réforme de l'assurance chômage adoptée
au mois de novembre qui nous a permis de
découvrir une notion à la contrat
cyclicité Emmanuel Macron l'avait dit
beaucoup plus simplement quand ça va
bien audurcit les règles quand ça va mal
on les assouplit un texte bien sûr qui a
beaucoup plus convenu à droite qu'à
gauche mais alors il y a certains textes
qui ont obtenu l'adhésion des deux côtés
des missions il y a eu quelques
consensus alors on le comprend très
facilement pour certains textes
consensuels de nature comme la
proposition de loi qui vise à lutter
contre la précarité des aesh les
accompagnants d'élèves en situation de
handicap c'est difficile d'être contre
même chose pour le texte qui est Inter
le démarchage commercial des titulaires
de CPF vous savez ces coups de fil
intempestifs qui font qu'aujourd'hui de
la plus personne ne répond lorsqu'on ne
connaît pas le numéro de téléphone qui
s'affiche sur votre portable mais la
gauche plus surprenant a aussi voté
d'autres textes comme la loi locmin la
loi sur les moyens du ministère de
l'Intérieur la droite et le Centre ont
voté le texte mais aussi quasiment tout
le groupe socialiste elle a aussi voté
la gauche le projet de loi pour
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables un texte qui donne lieu à
une bataille rangée à l'Assemblée au
Sénat le texte a atterri dans le
consensus avec des écologistes des
socialistes qui ont mêlé leur voix à la
droite au centre comme quoi entre
l'Assemblée le Sénat vous avez vraiment
des nuances différentes de bleu mais
aussi de rougeoir de verre et pour
l'instant le gouvernement a beaucoup
plus facilement travaillé au Sénat quel
Assemblée nationale il est donc loin le
temps ou le Sénat ou les sénateurs
étaient considérés comme les empêcheurs
de tourner en rond il est loin le temps
donc du premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron le gouvernement compte d'ailleurs
sur les sénateurs pour 2023 pour la
réforme des retraites
immigration ou encore le texte sur le
nucléaire merci Tom pour toutes ces
infos donc ils avaient de bande 3 jours
3 nuits par semaine vous savez pourquoi
elle nous dit ça parce qu'il y avait le
karaoké de fin d'année de la rédaction
de gluc c'est l'une des chansons qu'on a
qu'on a chanté voilà je vous dis tout ce
soir à tout à l'heure
allez on va continuer donc ça c'était le
flashback sur l'année 2022 au Sénat Gary
Slimane pour vous l'événement politique
le plus marquant de l'année c'est quoi
alors il y en a deux le premier c'est
quand même la guerre en Ukraine pour ce
que ça pour ce que ça c'est la première
fois depuis la guerre en exougoslavie
qu'on a un conflit on oublie souvent de
le dire d'ailleurs que c'était déjà
arrivé pendant la guerre en exclus la
vie qu'on a un conflit en Europe c'est
quelque chose qui a complètement
bouleversé la situation économique les
perspectives et pour ce qui m'intéresse
les perspectives des Français sur
l'avenir et qui a fracassé notre moral
économique et notre confiance en
l'avenir et puis l'autre événement c'est
la réélection d'Emmanuel Macron parce
que ça n'est jamais arrivé
de se faire réélire sous la Cinquième
quand on n'était pas passé par la case
cohabitation précédemment et donc c'est
quelque chose qui est tout à fait
exceptionnel même si du coup il démarre
sa popularité comme il terminait celle
de son dernier quinquennat c'est-à-dire
à des niveaux qui sont pas incroyables
non plus oui c'est ça on peut voir le
41 % de d'opinion favorables la question
c'est diriez-vous que même Macron est un
bon Président de la République on est à
41% de oui 59% de de nom de Catherine
tricot alors effectivement cette
réélection elle est historique
le législatives en ont changé le sens
d'une certaine façon on peut on peut
dire ça oui moi j'ai retenu deux
événements qui ont avoir avec
les événements ce sera ce sera chacun
son tour là je vous demande d'analyser
le la popularité ou l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron d'une certaine façon
c'est une élection moi je pense qui
c'est quand même passé un peu
bizarrement c'est à dire qu'en effet il
parvient à se faire élire dans le cas
d'un
paysage politique qui est quand même
très fracassé mais en absence de débat
c'est je crois que on paye et on pèse
sur le climat politique le fait que le
débat a été très escamoté et escamoté
par la présence de la par le surplomb de
la guerre en Ukraine qui a bouleversé
véritablement notre regard à tous et par
le fait qu'il n'y a pas eu de débat
entre Emmanuel Macron et les autres
candidats ça veut dire que ces
propositions n'ont pas été véritablement
discutés et que du coup la discussion
qu'on avait précédemment sur le sens par
exemple de sa mesure phare sur les
retraites n'est pas comprise elle n'est
pas partagée donc c'était jamais arrivé
qu'un président sortant participe à un
débat de premier tour
je ne sais pas
si c'est un régime
là où je vous rejoins c'est que c'est ce
que nous disait les gens ils avaient
l'impression que c'était inéluctable bon
bah Macron va être élu voilà et il
n'avait pas d'idées à part sur la
réforme des retraites de quelques
mesures que ce soit qu'il portait qu'il
incarnait et donc il y avait une espèce
de l'acide et les débats ça peut être
autre chose qu'un débat de premier tour
ça pouvait être simplement porté devant
les Français ce qu'il ce qu'il allait
leur proposer et ça c'est vrai que ça
manque aujourd'hui et ça et ça doit lui
manquer à lui aussi oui moi je pense que
ça lui manque et je pense ça n'a jamais
eu lieu mais enfin les enjeux sont
auxquels on est confrontés que ça se
fasse en tout cas là aujourd'hui il paye
à mon avis et nous souffrons tous que de
cette élection escamotée parce que le
second tour Marine Le Pen Macron c'est
un débat qui n'est quand même pas tout à
fait satisfaisant pour convaincre si on
fait un peu d'histoire là si on monte
dans le temps effectivement vous évoquez
les les des réélections de François
Mitterrand et de Jacques Chirac en
période de cohabitation leur popularité
un an ou 6-8 mois après après leur
édition elle était quoi beaucoup plus
haute que c'est Macron aujourd'hui
nettement même j'étais regarder François
Mitterrand en décembre 1988 et Jacques
Chirac en décembre 2002 avec d'autres
instituts d'auxales à l'époque BVA
ouifop il était 10 au moins 10 points au
dessus d'Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui je
rejoins effectivement Gaëlle
complètement la popularité de l'exécutif
étant de tiède une certaine manière
Emmanuel Macron n'arrive plus à
redécoller véritablement il est autour
de 40% à peu près chez tout le monde et
surtout surtout je trouve que son image
quand on regarde les enquêtes
qualitatives et très figées il y a plus
rien qui ressort et qui nous donne ce
sentiment un peu étrange d'un président
qui fait un exploit sous la 5ème
république d'être réélu hors période de
cohabitation mais il est là et il se
demande lui-même d'une certaine manière
qu'est-ce qu'il fait là peut-être c'est
des fois le sentiment qu'il donne
et tous les acteurs politiques
l'observent en disant où est-ce qu'on va
les Français eux-mêmes l'observent en
disant whisky veut aller où est-ce qu'on
va où est l'épine dorsales de ce
deuxième mandat voilà un peu la
situation dans laquelle on est ils sont
si je reviens vers vous pour voilà avoir
votre retour d'analyse sur le les
réseaux sociaux les médias sociaux et
donc la place que prend de nouveau en
fait pas un bilan de l'année mais
vraiment si on est dans le focus de de
ces de ces premiers jours de décembre il
reprend du terrain d'une certaine façon
il avait un tout petit peu disparu je
mets plein de guillemets au terme
disparu mais il reprend du terrain
alors il occupe le terrain et un
occupant le terrain il reprend du
terrain ce qui est on peut se demander
ce qui s'est passé d'ailleurs quel est
le contenu de de cette augmentation des
en tout cas des approbations même si les
mesures mais le vrai sujet du mois de
décembre ce sont les coupures
d'électricité au-delà de la Coupe du
monde que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure et
qui est plus positif et c'est vrai que
tout à l'heure Catherine le disait il a
lancé le sujet des coupures
d'électricité et après il est revenu en
décembre pourtant c'est le gouvernement
et dire mais en fait arrêter de paniquer
tout le monde il a il est intervenu pour
remettre un peu l'église au milieu du
visage du village sur ce sur ce plan là
et c'est une vieille on va dire c'est
une vie pratique de la Cinquième
République le président de la République
qui arrive et qui tend ce sont
gouvernement pour remettre de l'ordre
finalement et pour nous sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que c'est le sujet phare
de ce mois décembre c'est un peu la
raison pour laquelle il est revenu à la
fois en termes de mention et en termes
d'engagement il me dit vous êtes livré
un exercice de comparaison de Macron 1
et Macron 2 en termes de communication
ça donne quoi ça donne qu'il a bien
changé en fait le candidat en marche ce
président qui était fonceur ambitieux
qui voulait manager la France comme une
start-up on se souvient de ça convaincu
aussi qu'il pouvait faire bouger les
citoyens vers le progrès à coups de
phrase assassine je sais pas si vous en
souvenez mais sûrement les Gaulois
réfractaires le pognon dingue qui est
dépensé pour les minimas sociaux et puis
le maladroit il suffit de traverser la
rue pour trouver du travail donc tout ça
on s'en souvient c'était ce même
président jupitérien aussi qui voulait
lancer des réformes à tour de bras grâce
au vote qui était à l'époque homogène et
majoritaire de ces députés qu'on
appelait même les députés Playmobil et
donc il a changé pourquoi alors ben oui
parce que les crises sont passées par là
on en a beaucoup parlé déjà le bon élève
à qui tout réussi a été contrarié assez
réformes et même dans son style
finalement le mouvement des gilets
jaunes d'abord on en a pas encore parlé
mais ça a beaucoup marqué son premier
quinquennat ça a changé sa trajectoire
économique il était plutôt sur une
politique un peu libérale un
pro-entreprise il y avait même eu la
suppression de l'ISF et puis on arrive
sur quoi sur des coupes sur les impôts
on baisse les impôts pour les ménages
les gilets jaunes ça aussi modifié sa
façon de dialoguer pour calmer toutes
les rancœurs et cette colère il a lancé
le grand débat national la convention
citoyenne pour le climat dont on peut
discuter un peu les résultats et puis il
y a eu la crise sanitaire évidemment
avec le covid qui a poussé Macron à
protéger les Français il a renforcé
l'étape Providence avec un quoi qu'il en
coûte qui est devenu quasi permanent
puisqu'il est toujours d'actualité
quasiment avec la gare en Ukraine dont
on parlait le président de la start-up
nation est-ce qu'il s'est assagin d'une
certaine façon au travers de ces crises
mais en tout cas son deuxième
quinquennat commence pas sous les
meilleurs hospices et on l'a dit il est
en petite forme à la fois côté
popularité et puis dans ce qui déclare
sans majorité absolue à assembler c'est
difficile de lancer les réformes
annoncées fin de vie immigration
retraite Macron de multiplie les sujets
de réforme mais tout en repoussant à
chaque fois les échéances face à un
compromis qui est difficile à faire
émerger il tente de mieux dialoguer avec
des outils comme le Conseil national de
la rue fondation dont en tout cas
personnellement je cherche toujours un
petit peu la valeur ajoutée et il met en
scène ses colères on en a parlé à
l'instant quand la communication choisie
de ces ministres ne lui convient pas et
je parle des quoique sur le délestage
une grande colère sur ce qu'ils avaient
fait les projets de loi aussi sont actés
à coup de 49-3 c'est nouveau aussi et
pour compenser peut-être et parfois en
court-circuitant ces ministres le
président se fait le plaisir d'annoncer
ces petites révolutions par les réseaux
sociaux c'est un peu son mode de
communication préféré et il fait même le
service après-vente de ses propres
annonces on écoute
alors je dis banco allons-y donc on va
faire travailler les équipes pour
étendre cette mesure aux mineurs et donc
tous les mineurs et les majeurs jusqu'à
25 ans on va mettre en place cette
politique je pense que c'est une très
bonne politique de prévention pour
permettre à tous les jeunes de se
protéger le constate une grande ambition
nationale qui est dans 10 grandes
agglomérations 10 grandes métropoles
françaises de développer un réseau de
RER la première intervention c'est les
préservatifs
et donc en gros c'est plutôt que des
grandes réformes on annonce des mesures
sur les réseaux sociaux mais alors là la
rentrée 2023 elles sont non ce pas moins
compliquées inflation possible coupure
de courant grève dans les transports
c'est quand même assez compliqué pour ce
président déjà contrarié alors il y aura
peut-être et Gaëlle en parler tout à
l'heure quand même un peu de répit d'ici
quelques jours puisque si on imagine
voyez où je veux en venir quand on gagne
que l'équipe de France gagne à la coupe
de du monde de football en effet ça peut
peut-être lui donner en tout cas un élan
ponctuel pour démarrer l'année sous des
meilleurs hospices en tout cas qui
souhaitent mais surtout on souhaite ça à
la France effectivement en fait on va on
va tous être d'accord là pour croiser
les doigts pour pour les Bleus dimanche
16h allez deuxième événement marquant
Catherine tricot cette fois-ci vous
pouvez nous le révéler ça ça concerne le
rassemblement national oui c'est
l'entrée de Marine Le Pen avec un groupe
vraiment très conséquent puisqu'en fait
elle a le deuxième groupe à l'Assemblée
et le premier groupe d'opposition moi ce
qui me frappe donc d'une part c'est le
fait qu'elle a réussi à gagner des
élections dans un scrutin majoritaire de
façon significative ce qui n'était pas
du tout le cas auparavant donc ce qui
montre quand même un seuil qui a été
franchi et la deuxième chose qui me
semble intéressante aussi à noter et qui
tu dois être le l'objet d'une réflexion
pour tous c'est que elle réussit son
atterrissage sur le mode notable c'est à
dire que en fait la tranquillité avec
lequel elle s'installe dans l'assemblée
elle elle joue là présidente future 10
voilà elle joue l'autorité le calme etc
et que ça marche c'est à dire qu'en fait
il ne faut pas croire que c'est simple
les Français attendent des politiques
qu'ils soient raccords avec leur
sentiment leur ressenti dans l'existence
mais aussi qu'ils incarnent une
perspective politique ce que Marine Le
Pen parvient à faire et pas toujours à
mon avis de l'autre côté de l'hémicycle
où on fait beaucoup de bruit pour
manifester l'indignation la colère de
mécontentement mais que la partie
proposition
relève de du gouvernement actuel n'est
pas assez présente et incarnée
on est plus en réaction face au projet
qu'en proposition c'est exactement ce
que je veux dire c'est que je pense que
pèse beaucoup évidemment l'absence de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans l'hémicycle
c'est-à-dire que je le pense
c'est-à-dire que Marine Le Pen apparaît
comme une solution alternative à
Emmanuel Macron tandis que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon n'est pas là et que pour
l'instant Mathilde Panou n'a pas tout à
fait encore l'expérience et la surface
pour le faire mais que c'est pas
simplement un problème de mathildepanou
c'est aussi une aide une manière que la
France insoumise a de concevoir son rôle
politique qui est de d'incarner la
colère je pense que incarner la colère
ne suffit pas pour être une alternative
politique concernant Marine Le Pen Gael
Slimane c'est intéressant de voir le
baromètre des personnalités politiques
préférées des Français elle est elle est
toujours très haut oui et pour illustrer
ce qui vient d'être dit et j'y souscrit
pleinement quand on regarde les études
d'opinion et qu'on voit comment elle a
réussi sa dédiabolisation aidé vous vous
souvenez envoyer ça dans le baromètre
politique par la persévérer que Zemmour
elle avait fait tout un travail de
dédiabolisation mais il y avait quand
même un plafond de verre et grâce à Éric
Zemmour elle va finalement elle a
parfaitement réussi elle est aujourd'hui
deuxième et quand je dis aujourd'hui
c'est fait des mois qu'elle est deuxième
sur notre cote des personnalités
politiques que les Français préfèrent ou
qui ont le plus haut niveau de le code
d'adhésion derrière Edouard Philippe et
donc qui est peut-être un petit peu en
retrait on va dire comme ça donc parmi
les personnalités politiques vraiment
actives présentes elle est numéro un
aujourd'hui c'est une dizaine de points
de plus que Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
surtout comme elle a réussi sa
dédiabolisation ces personnalités là
sont des personnalités clivantes
Mélenchon ou Le Pen et donc elle est
assez haute structurellement dans notre
code de rejet puisque notre indicateur
mesure l'adhésion mais aussi le rejet à
l'égard de certaines personnalités
politiques et Marine Le Pen elle baisse
en rejet elle monte en adhésion
effectivement elle donne le sentiment
d'être moins dans la colère donc de
faire moins peur elle est de très loin
numéro 1 dans le cœur de l'ensemble du
peuple de droite si on met ensemble les
sympathisants LR avec les sympathisants
RN les sympathisants reconquêtes ceux
debout la France quand on prend tous ces
gens là elle est à 79% de codes
d'adhésion Jean-Luc Mélenchon il est 20
points derrière auprès du peuple de
gauche et donc elle a réussi ce pari là
et aujourd'hui on fait pas de politique
fiction mais si on se projetait sur un
un troisième match le pencron maliciel
serait de plus en plus incertaine je
crois qu'elle a aussi bien joué en
choisissant son thème de campagne qui
était le pouvoir d'achat qui est venu
avant même qu'on est ces questions là
qui reviennent sur la table avec
l'inflation avec la gare en Ukraine et
elle a joué vraiment et elle joue en
quelque sorte
le thème du pouvoir d'achat et même
vis-à-vis de la nupesse et de Mélenchon
qui a pas pu tellement jouer sur cet
aspect là donc c'est c'est très
particulier un mot de ces législatives
au-delà du score de du rassemblement
national est-ce qu'avec le recul le
résultat est plus facile à analyser
qu'est-ce que les Français ont voulu
envoyer comme message j'ai trouvé que
c'était vraiment un des événements
marquants peut-être ça m'a plu marqué
même que la présidentielle parce qu'au
fond à l'issue des élections
législatives on voit toute la difficulté
et toutes les tensions de notre
politique les Français n'ont pas donné
de majorité absolue à Emmanuel Macron et
ça aussi ça n'est pas anodin il est
arrivé à se faire relire c'était pas du
tout anodin mais sans majorité
absolue on a vu des forces politiques
qui étaient jusqu'à présent considérés
pendant longtemps comme des forces un
peu périphériques qui maintenant jouent
dans la cour des grands et se sont
installés durablement je pense au
Parlement moi j'ai étudié de près la
géographie électorale du mélange
chenille à la fois la présidentielle au
législatives on voit qu'elle véritables
bastions géographique mettant qui ont
été constitués patiemment depuis 2012
sur une décennie entière donc quelque
chose de très important c'est c'est
passé la même chose du côté du
rassemblement national et ces élections
législatives elles l'ont d'une certaine
manière symbolisée de manière
extrêmement forte et on voit que les
Français ont voulu passer comme message
à Emmanuel Macron et bien non ça n'est
pas open bar sur les réformes et ils lui
envoyait un message d'une certaine
manière très difficile pour lui-même à
décoder Gates Slimane vous l'avez évoqué
mais je crois qu'on a pas vu le
baromètre du rejet parce que c'est
toujours un élément vraiment intéressant
de du baromètre de Sam mascara où on
voit que Marine Le Pen elle est quand
même aussi sur le podium dans ce
baromètre là sur le podium mais pendant
a pas très longtemps quand on quand on
leur sait très méchant on nous pose des
questions du rejet quand on posait cette
très méchante question c'était pas très
compliqué on avait une Marine Le Pen qui
dépassait les 50% son père c'était bien
au-delà regardez le niveau d'Éric
Zemmour 64% de rejet le niveau de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon 7 points de rejet de
plus donc c'est quand même quelque chose
qui est qui est intéressant pour elle
d'arriver à atténuer ce niveau de rejet
et je rejoins ce qui vient d'être dit
sur sur le côté inédit on peut même le
dire comme ça vous êtes président dans
un système tel qu'il existe maintenant
avec les législatives derrière
normalement vous n'avez pas à vous poser
de questions vous avez votre majorité
mais dans les sondages que nous
réalisions sur les législatives les gens
nous disaient nous ne voulons ni d'une
majorité pour Emmanuel Macron ni d'une
cohabitation donc ils ont finalement
exactement obtenu ce qu'il voulait alors
dans ce baromètre des personnalités
rejetées on voit apparaître Sandrine
Rousseau avec ce 45 5% de rejet Bruno
cotress c'est votre événement marquant
aussi de l'année 2022 la percée
médiatique de Sandrine Rousseau je pense
que tout le monde autour de la table
sera d'accord pour dire que c'est la
personnalité politique qui a émergé
comment vous analysez cette personne je
pense d'abord qu'elle a elle est arrivée
dès la primaire des écologistes à
incarner quelque chose elle crève
l'écran à ce moment-là beaucoup
d'observateurs pensent qu'elle va gagner
et qu'elle va battre Yannick Jadot en
quelques mois elle arrive à devenir un
personnage et c'est ça que j'ai trouvé
comme événement vraiment absolument
incroyable à quel point Sandrine
Rousseau totalement inconnus sauf des
observateurs politiques devient un
personnage elle s'est elle campe un
personnage mettant dans notre vie
politique certains disent que c'est la
recherche du buzz permanent on peut
aussi dire qu'à travers le personnage
qu'elle est arrivée à inventer à
confectionner elle veut incarner des
thèmes qui sont des thèmes qui sont en
train de travailler en profondeur la
société française certes les le
vocabulaire de l'éco féminisme est un
peu loin des préoccupations des Français
j'en doute pas mais on voit qu'à travers
ça il quelque chose aussi qui est en
train de se jouer dans les nouvelles
générations en particulier sur des
thèmes comme les violences sexistes et
sexuelles évidemment l'égalité
homme-femme mais aussi voilà toute cette
nouvelle manière d'approcher la
politique et j'ai trouvé aussi un autre
point intéressant elle symbolise
peut-être toute la difficulté
aujourd'hui du parti écologiste puisque
le parti écologiste a beaucoup de mal à
convaincre les Français qu'il est le
meilleur défenseur de l'écologie il faut
peut-être une certaine forme de
radicalité pour qu'il arrive à imprimer
ça dans l'opinion et il est terriblement
concurrencé aujourd'hui par la France
insoumise sur la question de l'écologie
beaucoup d'électeurs potentiellement et
écologistes vont voter à la
présidentielle pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon
non pas simplement pour le vote
stratégique en disant c'est le mieux
placé mais aussi en disant c'est lui qui
a le meilleur programme sur l'écologie
donc voilà et de ce Manuela la
radicalité qui incarne Sandrine Rousseau
est intéressant aussi à analyse mais
Catherine tricot
c'était qu'au féminisme ou cette
radicalité c'est aussi facteur de
division à la fois chez Europe Écologie
univers ou chez les filles et accueillir
le il y a le dossier Julien Bayou
d'ailleurs on peut pas refaire les
conditions dans lesquelles on a une
Rousseau met en cause Julien Bayou on
dirait sur France 5 il y a beaucoup de
choses à dire à critiquer mais il y a le
dossier je viens Bayou il y a l'affaire
katnas enfin c'est des vrais facteurs
profondes division au sein de ces deux
parties moi je rejoins tout à fait ce
que vous avez dit c'est à dire que sur
l'écologie on peut pas dire que
Écologie Les Verts est convaincu mais
Sandrine Rousseau ne convainc pas du
tout elle fait 700 voix sa motion faut
se rendre compte elle fait 700 voix la
motion de Sandrine Rousseau cercaler
très très peu de votants aussi
le parti
pour t'exprimer pour la l'élection de la
nouvelle tout à fait certes on a un
parti qui est très étroit et à
l'intérieur de ce parti très étroit
elle-même est encore plus marginalisée
mais ce que j'allais dire c'est qu'en
effet il y a certainement une
crédibilité qui a été acquise par
Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur les questions
écologiques mais que ils sont en train
de vraiment gravement perdre parce qu'en
fait c'est un peu problème public
l'écologie elle féminisme ça se recoupe
quand elle dit les éco-féministe ça
marche dans la jeune génération et ce
qui est en train de se passer à la
France insoumise les risques de leur
coûter mais
ultra cher
moi ce que je trouve intéressant en
observant les données enfin l'opinion
c'est que
on dit souvent parler de moi bien parler
de moi mal l'essentiel c'est qu'on sait
qu'on parle de vous mais ça n'est pas
vrai c'est à dire que si à chaque fois
que vous prenez la parole vous vous
créez quatre détracteurs pour un
adhérent c'est pas une bonne politique
c'est pas efficace en l'occurrence quand
on observe Sandrine Rousseau dans notre
baromètre oui elle a fait fondre il y a
trois indicateurs adhésion rejet
indifférence elle a fait fondre
l'indifférence ce qui est le lot commun
de beaucoup d'hommes politiques en
revanche elle est c'est un cas unique
elle a 45% de rejet 10% d'adhésion elle
ne gagne rien c'est-à-dire qu'à chaque
fois qu'elle prend la parole elle
suscite de la colère des hommes et des
femmes qui trouvent que ces propos sont
d'une immense violence qu'elle est j'ai
oublié le mot l'inverse de misogyne je
l'ai appris récemment il y a un mot qui
on le cherchera vous verrez c'est
intéressant il doit y avoir le Henri
André dedans mais quelque chose
chose grâce à vous elle est elle
l'incarne aujourd'hui et de ce point de
vue là c'est intéressant quand même pour
les politiques de se dire le fait de
faire le buzz et d'exister immédiatement
n'est pas toujours un bon une bonne
opération Éric Zemmour l'avait vécu un
petit peu au moment de la campagne
présidentielle on ne voyait que lui il
marquait des points en intention de vote
et on voyait sa cote de rejet progresser
aussi donc il faut pouvoir doser les
choses et pour le coup je pense que ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas quelque chose qui
est efficace pour elle merci beaucoup
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce débat et à vivre sans si évidemment
avec nous en duplex passer de belles
fêtes revenez nous en pleine forme en